now to the spanish island of la palma
where there's no end in sight to a
volcanic eruption that has displaced
thousands of people and now there's an
unprecedented rescue mission underway
dan johnson from our partners at bbc has
more
more than 7 000 people have been
affected here now evacuated from their
homes in this massive exclusion zone
we're right on the edge of it here in
the shadow of the volcano and that
volcano only seems to get more active
day by day more lava is pouring and it's
actually grown over the last month and
here is where the lava is going right
down the hillside towards the sea but in
its path it's taken out all the farmland
the homes the villages the businesses
there's a home with a yard that has had
three dogs that had to be left there and
they have survived for the last month
those three dogs on food that's been
flown in and dropped by drone they've
been fed and given water via the drone
for the last month and now they're going
to attempt using a net hung from the
drone to actually rescue the dogs to
scoop them up and to take them to safety
that's a really daring difficult rescue
mission we'll have to see if that is
successful or not but the main question
is how much longer is that going to
continue how much more lava will be
produced and how much more destruction
will it cause for cbs news this is dan
johnson bbc news la palmer
thank you dan johnson now of course
we're all worried about the dogs
they got to figure out a way to get them
yeah yeah figure out a way to work that
out i'm the best in the meantime that
drone drop of food and water is pretty
cool yeah yeah